let me ask you this
because somebody wrote me this long
email
and i think you're the perfect person to
ask this
um you mentioned love
from a genetic perspective
what what's what is it what
what do you make of love why why are we
why do we humans fall in love
in your own life why did you fall in
love you know
the email that was written to me was
you always talk about mortality and fear
of mortality
but you don't ask about love
some i don't know if there's some
thoughts you could give about
the role of love in your own life
or the role of life the role of love
in human life in general i think
love in many ways defines my life it's
basically i like to say that i'm a human
first and a professor
second and uh i think this passion
for life this passion for you know
everything around us
i mean the only way to describe that is
love it's basically
you know embracing your
you know emotional self embracing the
you know the
[Music]
the the non brainiac in you embracing
the
sort of intangible the
not very well defined and even in my own
my own research
i'm just very passionate about
everything i do and you know there's a
certain passion that comes with
and what i'm sorry again being greek the
etymology of the word passion
what was passion passion is suffering
the etymology when we talk about the
passion of the christ it's the suffering
yeah and in the greek version of that
word pathos
like pathology pathos is
deep suffering it's the concept and
someone who's sympathetic sympathetic
means suffering together
experiencing emotions together so it's
funny that you ask me about love and i
respond with passion
passion for life passion for research
passion for my family for my children
for
you know so um there's there's a certain
passion that uh defines me
and everything else follows rather than
the other way around i'm not
first thinking with my brain what is the
most impactful people we could write and
then going after that
i'm thinking with my heart what am i
passionate about which drives me which
just like you know makes me take and
that's a beautiful way to live
but i i love it how the greek part of
you just kind of connects it to the
suffering so
if you could remove the suffering no no
no no when i say
suffering i don't mean suffering as in
being miserable
i mean suffering as in being emotionally
invested in something
remember i mean again if you if you look
at this poem what is it saying it's
saying
birds who love are birds who cry
right it's that's the very definition of
love
yeah exposing your fragility if you're
not afraid of suffering
you don't fall in love as soon as you
hold back
you protect you shield your heart no
love can enter
so there's this uh simon garfunkel song
i am a rock i am an island
and a rock feels no pain and an island
never cries so again there's some
aspects of that
into this poem the you know the fact
that
um you know but you told me you know
there i told you darling sweet that
forever love would keep is this
intermediate thing and then if there's a
recall but you told me you were right
birds could love or burst who cry
so it basically says that love is the
fragility
that you're willing to give to another
person it's opening up
your uh vulnerable spots
it's sort of accepting that
there's no safety net you're just giving
yourself fully
and you're ready to be hurt
you